[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by the
president of the republic of finland and
the prime minister of sweden
so
so
so
please please be seated thank you
it's not only a beautiful day
this is in my view and the view of
my team a momentous day
it's a very very good day
today i am proud to welcome
and offer the strong support of the
united states
for the applications of two great
democracies
and two close highly capable partners
to join the strongest
most powerful defensive alliance in the
history of the world
two proud independent countries
exercising the sovereign right
all states possessed
to decide their own security
president anisto you are uh and prime
prime mr anderson anderson you're uh
it's a great honor to have both of you
here at the white house
as finland and sweden began the process
of joining nato
it was out of the wreckage of world war
ii
that nato was formed
and in seven decades it followed
nato has proved itself an indispensable
alliance
committed to europe whole
free and at peace
but in recent years
doubts began to arise
was nato still relevant
was it still effective
is it still needed in the 21st century
world
today
there is no question
nato is relevant
it is effective and is more needed now
than ever
the indispensable alliance of decades
past
is still the indispensable alliance for
the world we face today
and i would argue tomorrow as well
and the decision of sweden and finland
the one they have made is testament to
that commitment
this is about the future
it's about a revived nato that has the
tools and resources the clarity and
conviction to defend our shared values
and lead the world
sweden and finland
already among our closest partners on a
range of issues
from strengthening peace and stability
to advancing human rights
to taking on climate the climate crisis
and addressing food insecurity
from strengthening the global health to
promoting development
finnish and swedish troops
finnish and swedish ships have already
served shoulder to shoulder with u.s and
nato forces
in kosovo in afghanistan and in iraq
and both finland and sweden are already
working in coordination with the united
states and our other allies and partners
to support the brave people of ukraine
as they defend their freedom against
russia's invasion
sweden and finland
have strong democratic institutions
strong militaries
and strong and transparent economies
and a strong moral sense
of what is right
they meet every nato requirement
and then some
and having two new nato members in the
high north
will enhance the security of our
alliance
and deepen our security cooperation
across the board
today
the president the prime minister and i
had a very good discussion about nato
accession
about the war in ukraine and
strengthening transatlantic security
but our conversations began well before
today
president anisto and i spoke last
december
and again in january and the weeks
leading up to russia's unjust and
unprovoked assault on ukraine in march
president came to the white house
came to the white house to see me
to discuss this brutal conflict
and the rupture
it's causing in europe
while we were in the oval office
together
we picked up the phone and we called
the prime minister
and the three of us all spoke
and we spoke again last week
when i invited them to come to the white
house today
we have consulted closely at every stage
as sweden and finland made their their
determinations
and today i am proud to assure them that
they have the full
total complete backing of the united
states of america
today
my administration is submitting to the
united states congress
reports on nato accession for both
countries
so the senate
can efficiently and quickly
move on advising and consenting to the
treaty
i greatly appreciate senator schumer and
mcconnell's support
as well as senator menendez and rich
to move this through the senate as
quickly as possible
once the perspective of all allies are
addressed and nato adopts the accession
protocols
the bottom line is simple
quite straightforward
finland and sweden
make nato stronger
not just because of the capacity of
their strong strong democracies
and a strong united nato
is the foundation of america's security
by joining nato allies make a sacred
commitment to one another
that an attack on one
is an attack against all
it's article five
of the washington treaty
and the core building block of our
alliance
and the only time in history
article 5 has been invoked
was after 9 11
when the united states was attacked and
all our allies rallied to our side
the united states will never forget that
and we will never fail in our pledge
to defend every single inch
of nato
territory i welcome sweden and fi and
finland
choosing that responsibility as well
it's going to benefit all of our people
and today
the president prime minister and i
committed that we're going to work
together to remain vigilant
against the threats to our shared
security and deter
and confront any aggression while
finland and sweden are in this accession
process
there's nothing going to be missed as my
mother would say between the cup and the
lip
we're in
once it is moving forward i really mean
it
i really mean it so let me be clear
new members joining nato
is not a threat to any nation
it never has been
nato's purpose is to defend against
aggression that's his purpose to defend
and let makes let me make let let no one
make a mistake
the meaning of this historic day
in the face of aggression
nato has not grown weaker or more
divided
it has grown stronger
more united
with finland and sweden's decision to
request membership in nato
it'll be enhanced for all time
standing together today will reject the
bloody creed that might makes right and
we declare more
more powerful creed
all for one and one for all
because what nato makes strong
isn't just our enormous military
capacity but our commitment to each
other
to its values
nato's alliance of choice
not coercion
this is a victory for democracy in
action
finland and sweden are seeking to during
nato because their citizens demanded it
and their elected leaders heard them
that's how it works when leaders derive
their power
from the consent of the government
from the consent of the government and
that's why nato's open open door has
always been so important
it allows nations to choose for
themselves
to ask to be part of a group of nations
that value freedom
democracy and human dignity above all
else
countries must demonstrate that they
meet nato's high standards for military
interoperability
economic transparency
and democratic accountability
that's what sweden and finland have done
and so today
it's an affirmation
of those countries in europe that share
our values
that we're willing and able to do what
it takes to be part of the alliance
nato's door remains open
in just a few minutes
i'll be leaving to spend time
with two of our indo-pacific allies
within a half hour so i'll be flying to
the republic of korea
and japan
i thank
i thank the president and the prime
minister for traveling here
on this meet for this meeting before i
take off because it is so important
america's alliance in europe and in asia
keep us and i would argue the world
strong and secure
they're how we confront the challenges
of our time
and deliver
the liver for our people today
and harness
harness opportunities for better
tomorrow
and i look forward soon calling sweden
and finland our friends partners and
nato allies
i want to thank you both for being here
and i'm going to invite each of you to
say a few words and we'll start mr
president
the podium is yours
mr president
it is with great pleasure
and honor to be standing here today with
you together with the swedish prime
minister magdalena anderson
we are here
for a very good reason
together we are taking a historic step
by seeking to join the north atlantic
treaty organization
finland has made its decision after a
rapid but a very thorough process
the process has once again revealed
the strength of finnish democracy
starting from the strong public support
the decision was made with an
overwhelming parliamentary maturity and
it also
enjoys a huge strong popular support
i want to thank you mr president
for your steadfast support
throughout this process
in early march i visited white house
and you encouraged
us to go further
that was of vital importance to our
process
your statement yesterday and our
trilateral meeting today are a testimony
of enduring commitment
the united states has made to european
and
transatlantic security
i want to assure that finland will
become a strong
nato ally
we take our security very
seriously the finnish armed forces are
one of the strongest in europe
we have also consistently invested in
developing our capabilities
the finn's willingness to defend their
country is one of the highest
in the whole world
we are ready to contribute to the
security of the whole alliance
making the commitment to mutual security
currencies that being a nato ally
entails
now that we have taken this
first decisive step
it is time for nato allies to wait in
we hope for strong support from all
allies and
for a stiffed ratification of our
membership once it's agreed
i believe that the united states can set
a crucially important example to others
the turkish leadership has recently
expressed concerns about our membership
application
i want to address these concerns today
finland has always had broad and good
bilateral relations to turkey
as nato allies we will commit to
turkey's security just as turkey will
commit to our security
we take terrorism seriously we condemn
terrorism in all its forms
and we are actively engaged in combating
it
we are open to discussing all the
concerns
turkey may have
concerning our membership in an open
and
constructive manner
these discussions have already taken
place and they will continue in the next
days
24th february
i said that the mosques have fallen
and we see only the
cold faces of war
russia's war in ukraine has changed
europe and our security environment
finland takes the step of nato
membership in order to strengthen
not only its own security but also in
order to strengthen wider transatlantic
security
this is not away from anybody like you
mr president said nato is protective
defensing
not a threat to anybody
at the same time we must not forget that
at this very moment the prey people of
ukraine
are fighting not only for their own
freedom and democracy
but for our common security
finland together with the eu and the
united states stands firmly behind
ukraine
so mr president once again i want to
thank you
for
making history with us thank you thank
you
mr president thank you for welcoming
president ninis and me to the white
house
the bonds between sweden and the united
states they are strong and long-standing
and as you know
swedes first set foot in your home state
of delaware in 1630
and we were one of the first countries
to recognize united states as an
independent nation in
1783
and since then our countries have
developed a deep and long-standing
friendship
through family ties
trade and mutual interest in interests
and i personally is very much one part
of this
but most of all
our shared values and beliefs
and democracy and freedom
values and beliefs that are now being
put
to the test
and today the situation in ukraine
reminds us of the darkest days of
european history
and i must say
that during dark times
it is great to be among close friends
and over these past months we have shown
transatlantic unity and strength at its
best
together we have responded forcefully to
russia's aggression
and provided unprecedented support to
ukraine
we have not flinched
and mr president
i want to thank you for the massive u.s
support to ukraine
and for your sustained engagement in
european society
president ninis and i have come here at
a historic moment for our countries
and for sweden
after 200 years of military and
non-alignment
sweden has chosen a new path
yesterday sweden and finland submitted
our formal requests to join nato
and russia's full-scale aggression
against the sovereign and democratic
neighbor
that was a watershed moment for sweden
and my government has come to this to
the conclusion that the security of the
swedish people
will be best protected within the nato
alliance
and this is backed by very broad support
in the swedish parliament
and with sweden and finland as members
nato will also be stronger
we are security providers
with sophisticated defense capabilities
and we are champions of freedom
democracy and human rights
we have a long tradition of extensive
military cooperation with nato
including all missions
and we are right now ramping up our
defense spending and we will reach 2
percent of gdp as soon as practically
possible
and mr president
your support for our country's nato
aspirations for our security are of
fundamental importance
and we look forward to a swift
ratification process by nato members and
we are right now having a dialogue with
all nato member countries including
turkey on different levels to sort out
any issues at hand
in the united states the senate is
crucial in this regard and last
sunday i hosted a delegation headed by
senate republican leader
mack mcconnell in sweden and later today
president ninis and i will meet senate
majority leader schumer and other
leading members of congress
and we greatly appreciate the broad and
strong support expressed by both parties
in congress
but mr president our countries also work
closer together when tackling global
challenges
and sweden
like other nordic countries has shown
that emissions reductions can go hand in
hand with economic growth
and in sweden right now
the green transition creates thousands
of jobs
through investments in battery factories
green mining and fossil free steel
production
and i actually brought the president a
unique example of this
a candle holder
hold holder made of the world's first
fossil free steel
[Applause]
and what we see in sweden right now is
that previously neglected areas are no
longer struggling with unemployment or
depopulation
but how to build housing infrastructure
and schools quick enough to meet up with
the expansion
and here i see fantastic opportunities
to cooperate between the nordic
countries and the united states
and i'm also proud that sweden
contributes to the us economy and the
prosperity of the american people
swedish companies are active in every
single state creating more than 350 000
jobs in the united states
and we are the 15th largest investor
mr president i want to thank you for
your leadership in our joint efforts to
promote democracy throughout the world
because democracy requires constant work
and safeguarding we have to win every
new generation
and let me conclude where i started
peace and stability in our part of the
world is the common security interest
for us
for you and for the rest of europe and
we stand here today
more united than ever and we are
committed to strengthening our bonds
even further
and sweden is prepared to shoulder its
responsibility as an ally in the north
atlantic treaty organization thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
you might be worried right now during
this vulnerable conversation the
president
do you plan on speaking to president
everyone
[Applause]
again